why do you think they're getting
divorced do you think divorce is fun I
think women divorce for no reason all
the time
you're actually a child what do you
think love is you're just like
romantically going away to Venice like
every year and that's like like no well
relationship requires a lot of
deliberate work things like chores and
where relationships start to break down
and it'll steamroll into bigger things
the whole argument is that I think
divorce is stupid over chores I think
that's stupid when you have a house
there's a lot of chores to there's a lot
of [__] to do around the house
a lot and she works all day bringing
that paper that's tax and then she goes
home and she's still got to do some work
it's gonna it's gonna take a toll and
she doesn't feel like it's separated our
work like that [__] it doesn't she
doesn't feel like the the the the work
is equally separated at home it's gonna
be a burden it's definitely gonna be a
burden you work all day you have to go
home and you have to click yeah you have
to cook then you have to clean then you
have to put the kids to bed then you
have to do a whole thing so you're
constantly draining you could do that
for a whole last week and then you won't
care because you know the passion of the
couple but after a couple of weeks it
it's really fast for you to be drained
you figure to yourself why am I drained
all the time because out of 24 hours you
work 18. it's a place where I'm supposed
to rest I don't feel like I'm rested I
feel like I'm always doing the job not
only I'm bringing all the money I'm
coming back home and I still gotta work
yeah it's going to be a pro it's gonna
definitely gonna be a
problem and [__] are gonna be
like you know what I'm gonna get me
someone that's actually your partner
when you have a Caribbean mom or that's
most mom I guess they come back home and
one thing to think I'm saying yo yo you
guys are ungrateful you never help me I
do everything about that's what they
talk about if your mama sees you on your
couch and you're not doing it and she
cooks she cleans and she works and she
brings a bill you don't bring anything
in the house she's gonna feel like
you're not doing anything and you're not
bringing anything in the house that's
what she wants so yeah I could believe
that 100 chores can be like a big ass
burden to someone when they come back
home and they want to commit divorce you
got that right yeah I think the only way
you could ever think that is if you
haven't ever lived with anyone and
you've got to live with a significant
other
only way you could talk like that hell
roommates forget a significant other
y'all ever live with roommates and one
person doesn't do they [__] [__] they
don't clean after themselves they don't
pay any of the bills they don't take any
of the trash out they don't do nothing
they just leave their [__] around no
hold up it's not even that you don't
just do anything it's that they create
more for you to have to do the
[__] left his dishes in there
wait for somebody else to do them and
then on top of that I can respect it if
you paid something extra I could respect
it if you do the trash or something you
did nothing and you left me extra labor
and you paid the same amount so you bet
you have the same amount but you bring
it to labor it's just like be you did
all this [__] and on top of that you're
gonna pee on the [__] no pick up your
piss [__]
watch puppy the [__] is this then I
gotta you expect me to clean this [__]
too yeah of course you're gonna be
pissed off everybody gotta do they part
when you get when you get older and you
manage your household on your own Pearl
you'll see how [__] annoying it is
when you're working and then you come
home and everything is [__] up and
horrible and nobody's [__] cleaning
anything yeah that is a totally valid
reason for divorce of course yeah chores
to break up a home our family have you
lived in a filter
person if it is consistent where you'll
consistently having to have that burden
upon yourself you keep telling them
please can you a lot of these people who
have these podcasts don't know what the
[__] they talking about they don't
actually have the experience so they
read up on it like nerds not knowing
what the lived experience is actually
like what the work is actually necessary
is easy to say chores but you ain't
never have to listen if your home is
filthy it don't feel like home if your
home is a place where you just have more
work than [__] you on the job 24 7. so
you take a chance off to get right back
on the shift at home who wants to go at
that point right so it's like yo not
having to go home after a long day of
work that is you if you rob someone of
that that will take a toll in no time
it's not gonna take long y'all ever have
your own place and then your mom got to
stay over for a week how long does it
take before you want your mom to get the
[__] up out of your weekend my [__] she
cleated she might even be cooking but by
the end of it and she's like bro I want
my home to be a [__] home and not my
mom looking over my shoulder telling me
when I'm picking up my underwear when I
want to be
don't say that because that's your mom
be respected but you get what I was
trying to say but hey on the inside you
best believe it
all right when you go back
disrespectful if you say it but you can
think it oh no and I don't thought a
whole bunch of the the number of times
you went to your roommate yeah yeah
you're gonna be like
yeah
what happened nothing it don't take long
yeah yeah yeah don't take long for your
home tonight you want them gone yeah so
if a significant others coming in and
creating that mess and doing all this
other stuff yeah it's like it's like
here's the thing if you care about me
why don't you just do your part
like see over there stressed because she
gotta do all this extra [__] and you sit
there on the couch enjoying yourself
she's not happy like how much do you
really care if you let your partner
having to take on all that burden
and you don't even be out there trying
to help in a tangible way you know what
I mean like like you pretty much the
same [__] you every day to your partner
like if I was with my [__] and they
saw me struggling with something on my
back you best believe they'd help to be
like yo let me carry some of that weight
if they did it is watch me struggling
the whole time yeah but I was struggling
with your bag why don't you just hire
someone to pick up your bag you know why
you're already that's like how much do
you really care that's a weird response
to seeing your partner struggle I ain't
gonna do it put your hand down put your
hand down put your head down
put your head down
okay now get naked
so everybody gonna put these two hands
out just in front of them
don't worry
um
[Music]
[Applause]
but the one that's left
that looks like mine the only reason
I personally love this wallet um I've
got my own right here and watch is great
it's minimalistic uh it carries
everything they look stylish
um and they come at really amazing
prices and I want you guys to be able to
do the same whether it's getting one for
yourself or one for significant other
because if you use the link in the
description below five percent off get
yourself an extra like this poop
lifelong friends from like grade school
to high school well dormant college and
then hate each other forever over like
bad dorm roommates and that's not even a
relationship so yeah of course I think
stuff like this is perfectly valid I
think I think splitting up and splitting
up splitting up duties in the households
like what are the most important parts
of like a relationship because it's
where you're spending most of the time
together that's why I say people get
triggered when I say I don't think
you're even dating until you live
together because until you live together
you don't really know what the other
person's like and once you start living
together and you see what the household
duties are like then you get a feel for
what the relationship is I mean I just I
just think that like I don't know I feel
like that stuff can be worked out chores
when you said it could be worked out
what do you think those women as their
husbands to do do you think their
husbands didn't do the trash for a week
and they said [__] I want a divorce is
that what you really think happens of
course not this is something that drags
on over an extended period of time and
there's a lot of toxic conversations
about this I feel exhausted can you do
some of the extra labor can you do this
can you do that can you do that it never
just happens where it's like I want a
divorce you didn't take out the trash
for two weeks yeah nobody it I don't
care who you are nobody is like that and
I say this only because I know guys who
work who their wives work and they fully
feel entitled to their women doing all
the labor at home this is very normal
especially from immigrant backgrounds
you know with the kind of way that times
are going right now women are having to
work because one man's income is not
enough to support a family so both
parties yeah these guys still are by the
old rules where even though they make
sometimes less money they still expect
her to do all the labor because that's
the rules so I'm not going to act like
these women are crazy when they say
chores I can imagine that shit's
annoying because I've had roommates I've
had relationships and I could tell you
if somebody don't pick up their weight
that [__] will eat at you man or woman
if somebody doesn't listen if you're in
a relationship as a man and you find out
your girl ain't been cooking cleaning or
doing none of that [__] you know you're
gonna be salty so why don't you think
she's gonna feel the same way when you
make her also have to take a job like
hold on wait do you understand your wait
wait hold on you're not saying anything
oh do you do this intentionally where
you're like I don't know about that
delineation of chores is one of the most
important things that if somebody's
constantly destroying the bathroom
leaving clothes everywhere leaving dirty
food in the sink they can't clean their
their dishes or whatever so it's like
destroying the bathroom what a great way
to say bro you're taking a big old [__]
no no I'm just saying I think of
bathroom destruction
yo [__] did you leave your [__]
toilet
you knew you left it you want to know
why because you flushed that [__] and
you went good luck [__] ah bro good
luck on the next one on my dookie yay
[__] we got a pleasure right don't make
me plunging your [__] booty hole bro
don't make me plunging your booty ass
pause I'm talking about the toilet ah
bro that's not what you said
oh my God I'm getting an anxiety attack
yeah let's move on low let me plunger
your booty hey bro why you gotta say it
in the slow motion that always sounds
worse the way you say
all right
let's move on let's move on let's move
on don't let me plunger your booty okay
do you why do you think they're getting
divorced do you think divorce is fun
that the because they're college
educated and they hate men they're just
like I'm just gonna divorce because I I
hate all men like why do you think I get
a voice I think women divorce for no
reason all the time okay shut that [__]
off shut that [__] off we're done shut
that [__] off I'm not even gonna dispute
just see see and
yo you're not divorces are embarrassing
yo they're you stressful yo they're
they're there's a lot of money involved
in that [__] you think a lawyer is free
shut that [__] off so I'm just gonna
divorce for no reason get
that whatever what not and then we're
gonna go nah man
you can you can say maybe the reasons
aren't great and you could try to make
that argument but for no reason like
they just like well I'm gonna get
divorced like okay cool story that's
that's yeah that's absolutely [__]
you just need to talk to more people
then because that's not true
you've never seen my street interviews
then I've done so many Street interviews
I talked to random strangers on the
street all the time and you and you find
women that get everyone's like oh you
know I just wanted to get divorced yeah
oh my God you're actually a child what
do you think love is you're just like
romantically going away to Venice like
every year and that's like like no well
relationship requires a lot of
deliberate work and things like hold on
hold on things like chores are where
relationships start to break down and
it'll steamroll into bigger things like
a guy not doing chores ever might be a
guy that you don't want to [__] anymore
and then you not having sex ever it
might be you guys just don't get along
anymore and then like three months into
it you [__] hate each other and you
don't know why and you're not sleeping
together even you're not having any sex
you don't do anything together and it
starts over small [__] but anybody
that's been in any relationship long
term I don't know how old you guys are
but if you've been in real relationships
long term these little things will pile
up and [__] kill you because they're
like the worst things relationships are
not like this puppy like romantic love
constantly it's doing the small things
every single day to make sure the
religious work have you been in a
relationship
the start of the relation the start of
the conversation should have been
have you been in a relationship no I
talked to people for a year next subject
but you're just like lol chores like I
don't know what that means like I just
think that you like why do you have to
let it get to that point I feel like
that's the guys
do you think it's controversial to say
that I think chores is a crazy reason to
get divorced and break up a home and put
your kid at every statistical
disadvantage that you possibly could no
because it's not just a choice I just
think that's just I feel like she just
chores chore and they're explaining it
and she doesn't remember no no she
doesn't want to just repeats her same
talking point tours
choice you probably can't pick your kid
up on time you probably aren't paying
attention to the needs of your [__]
wife okay you probably aren't keeping
other points like people you probably
are keeping other points like you can't
do chores everything else in life is
probably falling apart you should have
picked a better guy and then you know
what they need divorced
yeah yeah
it's like it's like you should have
picked a better guy or maybe the guys
can pick up what they gotta get done
maybe the ladies can do the [__]
labor that they're supposed to do like
why is it incumbent on the one person
who's doing most of the labor to
continue doing most of the labor in a
relationship where it's not reciprocated
why isn't the person why why isn't the
person who's not doing it picking up
they [__] side should people choose
better absolutely make sure you choose
right but you know what else is also
true
some [__] get comfortable yeah
and they start taking [__] for granted
yeah men and women
things could be one way one point and
then you get a couple years and all of a
sudden and a [__] change on you
yeah and a [__] gets comfortable
people change all the time yeah chores
what of course kids it's not about you
anymore I mean I don't really if
someone's get divorced fired but like I
just think once you have kids it's not
about you you can't help me stop using
this excuse of just pick a better guy as
a as an answer every time women aren't
happy about situation can we just hold
men accountable and just say please can
you help your woman out okay okay
thank you
the point the point of this is just to
argue to argue it's just like politics
you're not trying to better anything for
the people to try to understand what's
going on you're just trying to prove
that you're right and prove the other
one round that's not that conversation
is not going anywhere people are being
disingenuous and that so there's no
point in this conversation with these
people okay I'll say this whether it's a
relationship whether it's roommates
whether it's being on the team whether
it's being on a Workforce was starting a
business you need people to pull their
weight and nobody's trying to [__] be
involved with nobody who's not pulling
their weight you get involved in some
you ask somebody to do something and
they just refuse to do it like you're
going to be resentful officer sometime
you're going to break off that
partnership
that's true even for this YouTube [__]
if priest didn't do his job I didn't do
my part best believe we wouldn't last
this long you better do what the [__]
you got to do because if everybody got
to pick up F2 promise you promise they
gonna cover that neck at some point that
[__] will not last so I don't know why
this is such an outlandish thing if you
ain't not one of them six figures seven
figures dudes who paid all the bills and
taking out the extra financial
responsibility you don't have the right
to just sit there and be like she gonna
take care of everything and think like
you can do that but if she got a
grievance afterwards I ain't even gonna
be mad at her so it's not just a matter
of the women got to choose better
absolutely make sure you choose men that
do great but also like yo [__]
gotta step up man or woman step up to
the plate if you're gonna take on that
commitment understand it comes with
labor but putting all of that on your
partner that ain't right that ain't
right that ain't right and it wouldn't
be right in any other circumstance so I
don't know why you sit there in a
relationship and feel that entitled let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below